Video games are more popular than ever.
Games like Fortnight have gone completely
mainstream, and now almost everybody considers
themselves a gamer.
In the past, video games have been looked
down; they have been accused of causing habits
of violence or addictive behaviors.
But what about the benefits of playing video
games?
Here are some reasons you might want to game
hard in 2019.
One; video games are linked with emotional
stability.
Here at Psych2Go, we're all about helping
and educating others on everything related
to psychology, and emotional stability is
a huge part of that.
A 2012 study suggested that immersive games
in particular, appear to be the most beneficial,
because they allowed gamers to try out different
versions of themselves.
Games like Red Dead Redemption 2 are so immersive
that people can go anywhere and do anything.
We're allowed to explore our own personalities
and see what fits best with our ideal selves.
And according to research, this helps a lot
with emotional stability.
Three; video games improved Visumotor coordination.
You might have heard previously that video
games improve hand-eye coordination, it's
true.
In fact, a recent study found that video games
improve all Visumotor coordination which is
when vision and movement work together to
produce actions.
For example, in First-Person Shooters, gamers
must aim quickly and accurately at small targets.
In driving games, we make small steering adjustments
at high speeds.
When we boost our Visumotor coordination,
we get better at all kinds of tasks; including
walking, driving, sports and even basic tasks,
like getting dressed in the morning.
Four; playing certain video games boost social
skills.
We all know that in 2019, some of the best
video games are the ones we can play online
with our friends.
But until recently, no one really considered
the benefits of these games.
In 2014, a very interesting study was published
on the subject, which proposed that immersive
social video games help gamers develop pro-social
skills.
In these games, you have to figure out who
you can trust, who to make friends with and
how to lead a group.
And yes, those skills can definitely be transferred
from the game world in to the real world.
Five, videogames are linked with better vision.
We've been told that staring at a screen all
day is bad for our eyes, but what if videogames
actually improves our vision?
There have been quite a few studies on this.
Games can boost visual contrast sensitivity,
which is basically the ability to distinguish
between different shades of gray.
One study even found that videogame treatments
can cure a lazy eye, which is also known as
amblyopia.
That being said, don't stare at a screen all
day playing video games with the excuse of
trying to improve your eyesight.
Six; video games might help with dementia.
Almost everyone's a little fearful of getting
old, and one big reason is dementia.
Once again, it's video games to the rescue.
A 2016 study found that playing video games
helped older patients restore their cognitive
functions.
This included benefits like improving walking
abilities, better moods and better social
interactions with friends and family.
Seven; video games can help teens blow off
steam.
Being a teen isn't easy and most of us remember
having a lot of pent up emotions during this
time.
If anybody needs to blow off some steam, it's
your average teenager.
And according to a 2007 study, video games
are a great way to do that.
The study found that teens were relieving
a lot of stress by playing video games.
So instead of causing aggression, video games
might actually be helping teens vent by getting
aggressive in the game world instead of the
real world.
To summarize this video, what's your favorite
video game?
Comment below.
Share this video with a friend of yours who
plays.
Also, we started a Patreon recently, if you'd
like to support our mission to make psychology
more accessible for everyone, consider checking
out the link in the description below.
Five people will randomly get a free physical
Psych2Go to go magazine for simply donating
two dollars or more a month.